[MUSIC PLAYING]
[MUSIC - MAGIC GIANT, "SET ON
FIRE"]
[APPLAUSE]
ZAMBRICKI LI: So
we have a saying.
We say, it doesn't
matter who's to blame.
We're all in this together.
And that's one of the
things this song is about.
It's like, if the
ship is sinking,
we can either all kind of band
together to kind of save it.
Or we all just kind of go down.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
AUSTIN BISNOW: Want to
talk about this song now?
[MUSIC PLAYING]
ZAMBRICKI LI: So
sometimes, you know,
when you say
goodbye to somebody,
you don't realize
till years later
that it was your last goodbye
whether it's, you know,
that person goes off and your
lives just kind of depart
or whatever happens.
So we just try to treat every
goodbye like it's meaningful--
not that it's necessarily
your last goodbye,
but you just never know
what is going to happen.
BRIAN ZAGHI: Get
closer to the mic.
ZAMBRICKI LI:
Check, check, check.
[MUSIC - MAGIC GIANT, "GREAT
DIVIDE"]
AUSTIN BISNOW: Give that a try!
[MUSIC - MAGIC GIANT, "GREAT
DIVIDE"]
One more.
[MUSIC - MAGIC GIANT, "GREAT
DIVIDE"]
[APPLAUSE]
This is the first time I've ever
sat while singing, pretty much.
BRIAN ZAGHI: Yeah.
AUSTIN BISNOW: It's
so weird, right?
BRIAN ZAGHI: It's
weird and nice.
ZAMBRICKI LI: You're doing good.
You look good.
AUSTIN BISNOW: I'm trying
to fit in at Google,
although I did just slide
down the slide, which
is also very Google.
[LAUGHTER]
We did that at YouTube.
They have the same--
ZAMBRICKI LI: It's very us.
AUSTIN BISNOW: Exactly.
And I got shocked.
Do you guys get shocked
when you slide down?
There should be a sign.
Like, you guys all know that.
Yet you let everyone still go.
ZAMBRICKI LI: No one told us.
AUSTIN BISNOW: It's like, what
should we give the performers
right beforehand?
BRIAN ZAGHI: Yeah!
Yeah, they're telling
us, go down the slide.
Everyone goes on the slide.
You have to go down the slide
if you're new to Google.
Now we get it.
ZAMBRICKI LI: Cruel.
AUSTIN BISNOW: You want
to do "Shake Me Up"?
BRIAN ZAGHI: Sure.
AUSTIN BISNOW: So
we've been working
on an acoustic version of some
of the songs on the album,
a collection, secretly--
not so secret after
this comes out.
Hopefully we'll
release it in April.
And, yeah, we had
about five days
off in between
festivals in Florida.
And we recorded
some of these songs.
And so this is an
interpolation of one
of the songs from our album "In
The Wind" but very different.
I mean, it showed us
that, when you change,
it can be the same song.
And you change the,
you know, production.
And you feel it and
you interpret it
in a totally different way.
We just released a video
for this on YouTube.
And it's like a
full-on, you know,
football game and a dance.
And Zang's step-dad is, you
know, chasing his dream,
playing football--
his character is--
doing end zone dances.
But, yeah, let's
talk about a bit
about the meaning of this song.
Yeah.
Zambricki, you
were saying, like,
it came from a Bob Dylan
song, "Forever Young."
ZAMBRICKI LI: Yeah.
Originally, when I was playing,
thinking about the lyrics,
there's a Bob Dylan song
called "Forever Young."
And I read that he wrote it as
like a letter to his children.
So when I was working
on lyrics for this song,
I was thinking about it as like
a letter to our grandchildren,
so like one step further.
AUSTIN BISNOW: Trying to
one-up Dylan, you know?
ZAMBRICKI LI: Yeah, just
trying to one-up Dylan.
AUSTIN BISNOW: We never will.
ZAMBRICKI LI: Yeah.
Maybe we never will,
but, hey, we're reaching.
So, in the verses,
it's kind of like what
we want to say to them,
kind of like advice
even though they're,
maybe, far from existence.
AUSTIN BISNOW: None of
us even have children.
ZAMBRICKI LI: Yeah, we
don't even have children.
AUSTIN BISNOW: That we know of.
No, I'm just kidding.
ZAMBRICKI LI: And then,
you know, in the chorus
it's kind of like the
flip side of that.
Like, if we're lucky and we
do get to have grandchildren
and then they grow up,
then they can kind of
do the same thing back
for us and kind of give us
the same type of advice.
And, hopefully, if
we did it right,
then they'll be able
to pick us up, too.
AUSTIN BISNOW: So
in the chorus it's
like, if we get
stuck in our ways,
will someone be there
for us to pick us up?
And then, in the bridge,
we say, "Before it
ends, before we're gone, life's
too short, goodbyes too long.
Release yourself from the storm.
It rolls on."
And when we were
writing this, this
is the last song we
wrote for "In the Wind."
And we were writing it in
the studio like the day
we were recording
it and finishing it.
And Zang's dad had just passed
away a few months before that.
And he had suffered
from mental illness.
And this was just
like a "release
yourself from the storm.
It rolls on."
You can get carried
away with the storm,
or you can let it go.
This is called "Shake Me Up."
[MUSIC - MAGIC GIANT, "SHAKE ME
UP"]
LAURA MURPHY:
Actually, Zambricki,
if you don't mind, why
don't we start with you?
I want to do just a quick
little round of introductions.
Tell us about yourself.
ZAMBRICKI LI: Well,
my name is Zambricki.
AUSTIN BISNOW: Hi, Zambricki.
ZAMBRICKI LI: Hi.
And, yeah, I love
to write songs.
I play violin.
Today I was playing viola
for most of the show.
But I play mandolin
and Dobro and cello
and different
stringed instruments.
I was born in New Jersey.
And I've been playing
music my whole life.
I'm self taught.
And, yeah, just the last couple
years playing with these guys
and, you know,
writing this album
and doing everything
together has just
been like the most
fun I've ever had.
LAURA MURPHY: That's great.
ZAMBRICKI LI: Yeah,
we're excited.
LAURA MURPHY: Welcome.
Austin?
ZAMBRICKI LI: Did I hurt you?
AUSTIN BISNOW: I
guess I didn't realize
I had like a little
bruise already there.
ZAMBRICKI LI: I'm sorry.
AUSTIN BISNOW: No, no, no.
I'm Austin.
I'm from Washington, DC.
I went to school in
Colorado, Boulder.
I've lived in LA for
like seven years.
I road tripped out
there with a friend
and fell in love with it,
couch surfed for eight months
and then kind of
gradually moved there.
I've been writing
music since I was 12.
I broke my ankle playing
sports and my mom signed me up
for a songwriting camp.
And I didn't even know that
was a thing at the time.
Like, wait.
What's songwriting?
I thought songs just exist.
And I'm so very grateful.
And I'm so happy I met
these guys, as well.
LAURA MURPHY: That's great.
Nice.
And Zang?
BRIAN ZAGHI: Yes,
my name is Zang.
Thank you.
And I'm from I'm from
Los Angeles, California.
And I've been doing
music all the while,
my whole life, all
the while studying
to be a software engineer.
I was actually a software
engineer before this.
AUSTIN BISNOW: Are you saying
you can school these guys?
BRIAN ZAGHI: No!
I'm saying I haven't been in
it for the past few years.
ZAMBRICKI LI: Are you rusty?
BRIAN ZAGHI: So rusty.
LAURA MURPHY: Are you
looking for a job at Google?
BRIAN ZAGHI: Yeah.
This is--
ZAMBRICKI LI: This is all for--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUSTIN BISNOW:
It's the beginning
of the end of Magic Giant.
BRIAN ZAGHI: I heard that Google
interviews are like the most
complex and they give you
the hardest questions.
ZAMBRICKI LI: But if
you do a talk first,
then you've got like a leg up.
BRIAN ZAGHI: Exactly.
That's why I'm doing this.
I'm hoping, one day--
AUSTIN BISNOW: Tell them how
you started playing bass.
I don't know, I just
think it's funny.
BRIAN ZAGHI: The
first instrument
I ever played was an upright
bass, which at the time
was three times the size of me.
And it was in school.
First, on my schedule card,
it said all my classes--
math, this, that.
It said strings.
And, at the time, I
was a little nerd.
I was like, oh, cool.
Like, there's a string
physics class or something
with strings where I get
to learn how to use strings
in some cool mathematical way.
AUSTIN BISNOW: String theory.
BRIAN ZAGHI: Yeah,
sure, string theory.
That's what I was thinking
when I was nine years old.
So I get into the class,
and it's like an orchestra.
And everyone's
choosing instruments.
And so the teacher's
like, OK, everyone,
pick your instruments.
And in the distance I see
this closet of upright basses.
And I was like, I want that.
And I yelled it,
like, in the class.
I want that one!
And just, in my mind,
I had this vision,
you know, like me and this bass.
I would carry it on my back like
a super ninja musician turtle.
And, like, we would
just be best friends.
And I would always take
it home and practice it.
And that's what I did.
And it felt great.
LAURA MURPHY: Well, you not
only wield that special power,
but also you're a salsa dancer?
And that's how you sort
of started with these two?
Is that right, as well?
ZAMBRICKI LI: So we
actually kind of--
I don't know if it's
a professional term,
but we kind of like
Google stalked him.
BRIAN ZAGHI: So thank you, guys.
This is why--
ZAMBRICKI LI: And I don't know
if Google stalking is a term.
LAURA MURPHY: Bringing
the world together.
ZAMBRICKI LI: It was
more like a deep search.
After we met him,
we looked him up.
And one of the first
videos that popped up
was him dancing salsa.
And we were like, wow.
It was so foreign.
It was like an alien type of
skill set that the two of us
had never kind of experienced.
We were like, yeah, that's it.
That's a vibe we don't have.
So it was really good.
And we've since learned--
AUSTIN BISNOW: So
we were like, yeah.
Wow, the SEO on that's amazing.
We should to do a Google Talk.
Let's start a band so that
one day we will be in Detroit.
BRIAN ZAGHI: Yeah, it's strange.
I guess you guys are the
reason we're here right now.
LAURA MURPHY: I don't
know that we've ever
had a guest say that before.
So you guys just moved
to the top of the list.
Thank you.
And scene.
Just kidding.
ZAMBRICKI LI: But
it's interesting.
I never knew this, but he
dances salsa-- and very well,
by the way.
You can look it up on Google.
But there's a deep
salsa community
all over the country and world.
So now, when we're
touring, after the show
he goes salsa dancing.
And he'll like
disappear after the show
and come back like
super sweaty later.
I'm like, we just played a show.
You got super
sweaty, and then you
went and danced salsa for hours.
BRIAN ZAGHI: I'm already sweaty,
I might as well keep it going.
ZAMBRICKI LI: But
it's really cool.
Like, the tour
schedule and the salsa
schedule sometimes
just really coincide.
So it's nice that we can help
with your original passions.
LAURA MURPHY: It is
really incredible
to see the following
that you guys have
once you spend some time looking
on some of your social media
channels or going to
one of your live shows.
It's pretty cult like.
It's inspiring, as well.
So what would you say,
just a little bit more
about how the band gets
their name out there?
What would you say are the
best platforms for you guys
to not only connect with your
fans outside of live shows
but also to stay
connected to them?
BRIAN ZAGHI: Yeah, Google+
has been huge for us.
[LAUGHTER]
It's so big.
LAURA MURPHY: For real, though.
ZAMBRICKI LI: Ooh, they're
going to edit that out.
BRIAN ZAGHI: Sorry.
It's good.
AUSTIN BISNOW: One
thing that's actually
developed since we
released the album in May
is like a community--
they call themselves
the Magic Misfits--
of, like, the people
that come to our shows
and are all very supportive.
I mean, like, they'll come
to 13 shows in one tour.
And, you know, they'll
come to 30 shows a year
or whatever it is.
And so they'll get on there,
and they'll like share stories.
ZAMBRICKI LI: It's like an
old-school message board
kind of vibe.
So you go there and it's
all like [IMITATES TYPING]..
We're not members of it.
AUSTIN BISNOW: And
it's like a safe--
LAURA MURPHY: Oh.
You can't be?
ZAMBRICKI LI: I don't know.
We probably could be.
It just feels a little, like--
LAURA MURPHY: Creepy?
ZAMBRICKI LI: --creepy,
yeah, to be on there.
AUSTIN BISNOW: Let
them do their thing.
But, yeah, it's like
they're all so supportive.
And they're like, oh,
I'm going to Detroit.
Can I crash with anyone?
Or someone will be like, oh,
I'm coming from Ann Arbor,
ride with me-- you know,
like that sort of thing.
It's super cool.
I feel like that has developed.
It's such, you know, a core.
It's really cool.
LAURA MURPHY: To stay connected?
BRIAN ZAGHI: Yeah, it's cool.
And it's a way of saying
connected because, also,
in this digital age, it's not
as easy to stay connected.
But somehow it is feeding
and it is helping.
Like, the way that
they can connect online
and through all these platforms
that are being created
helps them connect and
build relationships
outside of the digital.
ZAMBRICKI LI: Well,
then it's also,
when they come to
the show, since they
know each other from
online, then it's
kind of like they
know each other.
And it's like--
BRIAN ZAGHI: Yeah,
the rapport is there.
ZAMBRICKI LI: They already
kind of know each other.
It's like online dating
except around our music.
LAURA MURPHY: It is.
Well, and I was talking about
that tour bus that's out front.
If you guys haven't had
a chance to check it out,
it's incredible.
It's amazing.
So let's talk a little
bit about the tour.
ZAMBRICKI LI: After
this, let's all go.
We can all pile in.
LAURA MURPHY:
We're all invited--
mimosas and bagels and whatever.
But let's talk a little bit
about how your tour is going.
I was looking at your schedule.
It's absolutely insane.
And if you didn't see
this on Instagram today,
these guys posted, "So
excited to be in Detroit."
They had a beautiful photo
from one of the last times
they were here.
It was taken outside
The Shelter, I believe.
And they're posting about
today being their day off.
And they're so excited
to be at Google.
I love these guys.
So today's their day off.
They're here with us.
I think tomorrow you're headed
to Toronto and then the East
Coast.
ZAMBRICKI LI: We head to
Toronto tonight, yeah,
and then the show is tomorrow.
LAURA MURPHY: So how
is the tour going?
Is there anything fun
you can share with us?
ZAMBRICKI LI: Yeah,
it's going great.
I mean, since, you know,
we're on our first album,
we're a fairly new band.
And now that we
have an album out,
it's been really
cool because a lot
of the people who come to
the shows kind of lived
with the album.
And they know.
So they're like
singing all the words.
So every night it's
like we get to the city.
Like, you know, last night
we played in Ann Arbor.
And we've only been
there once before.
So we kind of still
don't know what
to expect when we
go to these places.
And then we get in there
and everyone's, like,
singing the bridge.
BRIAN ZAGHI: Yeah, they
sing it louder than we can.
ZAMBRICKI LI: It's really cool.
Yeah, it's awesome.
So that's been kind
of connecting it,
where it's just like
been an awesome surprise
because some of these places we
haven't really been that much.
And, you know, the music's
out there in the world.
And, like, we see people
on social media and stuff.
But then it like makes it
real when you go there.
Then you can look
them in the eye.
And it's like, that's
right, you're real.
This is a real thing.
BRIAN ZAGHI: And one thing
I really love about the way
that we tour or just
touring in general
is that we're stuck together
for such a long period of time.
ZAMBRICKI LI:
[INAUDIBLE] you like?
BRIAN ZAGHI: Yeah, because then
we just start writing things.
And, like, it's really
cool that our writing
process kind of flourishes
when we're all together stuck
on a bus.
I mean, the last tour
we did last summer--
or two summers ago, I guess--
we toured in a mobile.
Like, we bought
this shuttle bus.
And we converted it into a
mobile solar-powered recording
studio that we took
along this tour that
was like in these beautiful
parts of the country.
And we were playing
these festivals.
And as we were
writing these songs,
we'd record parts of
the songs in, like,
a flower field in Crested Butte,
Colorado, or like an old--
ZAMBRICKI LI: Train tunnel.
BRIAN ZAGHI: --train tunnel in
Snoqualmie, Washington State,
so all these interesting
places where there are not
only beautiful scenery
but also these,
like, sound anomalies
that would sound
really cool on recordings.
ZAMBRICKI LI: Yeah.
So, basically, we looked
at our summer tour.
And we had all these
festivals and all these things
kind of popping up.
So instead of, like, booking
more shows to fill the gaps,
we actually booked
sessions out in nature,
so like the Redwood trees
in northern California.
There's this road called
Avenue of the Giants.
And they have these huge
trees, like half the size
of this room wide.
It actually sounds beautiful
in there, you know?
Like, in here we have foam.
And we're, like, doing all these
things to make it sound good.
But if you go inside of
a Redwood tree, like,
you're done.
It's like a million
dollar studio.
So that's where we
recorded some of the violin
parts, some of the banjo parts.
BRIAN ZAGHI: Like
inside of a tree.
The tree trunk has,
like, a cavern.
LAURA MURPHY:
Hollowed out, yeah.
ZAMBRICKI LI: So we would pull--
BRIAN ZAGHI: Naturally
hollowed out.
ZAMBRICKI LI: So we'd pull the
bus up to the side of the road,
greet the ranger or
whomever would pull us
over because they think we're
doing something nefarious.
AUSTIN BISNOW: Because
we didn't technically
have a session booked.
It was internal.
It was on our Google Calendar.
LAURA MURPHY: We did
it ourselves, yeah.
ZAMBRICKI LI: But it's cool.
It had a real, like,
Magellan kind of feel.
You look at the map.
And you're like, let's go
to Avenue of the Giants.
And you drive for like eight
hours, and then you're there.
You know?
AUSTIN BISNOW:
"Coming to America"
where he's like,
"I need a queen.
I'll go to Queens, New York."
ZAMBRICKI LI: I need
to make a record.
LAURA MURPHY: Amazing movie.
AUSTIN BISNOW:
Magic Giant, we'll
go to Avenue of the Giants.
ZAMBRICKI LI: So we pulled the
bus up to the Redwood Grove.
And then it's being
powered by the sun
because we have solar
panels on the bus.
And then we run
all the equipment--
the wires and the
equipment-- out and just--
AUSTIN BISNOW: Is
Google on the sun?
LAURA MURPHY: No, not yet.
ZAMBRICKI LI: You guys have
got to get on the sun, man.
LAURA MURPHY: We're
working on it.
ZAMBRICKI LI: And, I
mean, it's beautiful.
It's dead quiet because
we're not running generators.
We're not running power.
There's nothing going on.
There's not even
lights or anything.
Everything makes
little sound, you know?
When you add it all
together, it kind of creates
this noise floor.
So you go out in
nature, and it's just
completely dead quiet.
You have this beautiful
acoustic anomaly,
which is a Redwood tree.
And you record it there.
And it also makes it
so it's like now, when
we play the songs
and think back on it,
we have all these other
memories kind of attached to it.
It's really cool.
AUSTIN BISNOW: One
story from that
as we played the beginning of
"Jade," which is the opening
song on the album,
at this place,
Hidden Lake on Powder
Mountain, Utah.
Well, it was hidden
until I said that.
The first lyric is,
"Sang the bird forever,
and then she flew away."
And, as Zang played, like, the
first take, he played that.
And birds chirped
over that part.
And it gave us
chills in the moment.
Then we went back to the studio.
And we were like, wait,
is this too cliche?
ZAMBRICKI LI: It sounded like
we did it in Logic or something.
AUSTIN BISNOW: People are going
to think we added this in.
ZAMBRICKI LI: It sounded like it
was like, chirp, chirp, chirp,
like you flew it in a sample.
So we got a little
self-conscious.
We were like, OK,
can we take it out?
Let's just take it out because
it's a little on the nose.
And then we tried
to take it out.
But you can't take it out
because it's in the recording.
LAURA MURPHY: That's
the part of nature.
It's what you intended it to be.
ZAMBRICKI LI: Yeah.
So we just kind of
took it and then
like distorted it a little bit.
So it's like the album starts
with, like, distorted birds.
And that was kind of almost
the theme of the record.
It became, take these
things in nature.
And then we went
back to the studio.
We kind of like still
took the license
that you normally take when
you're making a record as far
as being able to kind
of manipulate the sounds
and create, like, the
colors that you want.
But we used it from, like, a
purely organic starting point.
LAURA MURPHY: It's
so fascinating
how completely in
tune you guys are
with a lot of things around
you, be it recording in nature
or what's going on in
the digital social world.
And I find it amazing that one
of your highest-viewed videos
on YouTube is the
one where you shot
from a chairlift or a ski lift.
And tell us a little
bit about that.
Was that a challenge
with the audio?
Or did you have to do a little
magic afterwards with that?
BRIAN ZAGHI: That
was a challenge.
A couple of things helped us.
One, they have these field
recorders that we would use.
So my guitar and his
banjo were directly
fed into this field recorder.
And then Austin, it
was all a selfie.
He was holding a phone.
And on that phone, there
are these external mics
that you can plug
into the phone.
And we used one from Shure.
Shure makes one that plugs
into the phone that has, like,
a pretty nice condenser
mic on that phone.
So we were recording--
ZAMBRICKI LI: And then we
take it back and blend.
There's actually one
other kind of trick
that you can do that
we've done before.
I don't know if we
did it on that video.
We may have done it,
like, on the banjo.
You actually just take
a phone and tape it
to the back of your
instrument and then use, like,
the voice memo inside
the phone, which they all
come with voice memos.
And the microphones
on these phones
are actually
getting really good.
So we'd tape it to the back
of the instrument-- like, say,
tape it to the back
of the guitar--
so you get like a really
close, direct sound.
You just try not to bang into
it when you're playing it.
So you kind of have to be
careful and conscious of it.
And then we go
back to the studio.
We can take all these
different sources.
And then we kind of do,
like, a regular mix.
So it becomes a
blend that you do.
So you can kind of like mix it.
There's some things
you can't take out,
you know, all that
kind of thing.
But you have a little
bit of flexibility.
So it's not like just the
phone in front of you,
which gets his vocal.
LAURA MURPHY: That's incredible.
I love it.
Your inspiration seems
to come from everywhere,
including the name of
your band, Magic Giant.
I read that it was
inspired by a TED Talk?
AUSTIN BISNOW: It's true.
BRIAN ZAGHI: It was
a Google Talk, right?
[LAUGHTER]
AUSTIN BISNOW: So,
yeah, it came from--
LAURA MURPHY: A TED Talk?
AUSTIN BISNOW: --a
TED Talk about--
ZAMBRICKI LI: He's just
kissing the ring whenever
he can over there, yeah.
LAURA MURPHY: It's OK.
Well, he's sitting
closest to me.
BRIAN ZAGHI: That's right.
ZAMBRICKI LI:
You're charming him.
LAURA MURPHY: You
want to hold hands?
ZAMBRICKI LI: I'm afraid.
AUSTIN BISNOW: --by this
visual artist, Peter Tunney.
And he was describing
his mentor,
who happened to
be Jonas Salk, who
came up with the cure for
polio among other things.
But he was describing
him as a giant
in every sense of the word.
And they showed a photo of him.
And he was like, you know, in
the low five-foot-something.
And we just thought
that was so cool.
You don't have to be
big to be a giant.
ZAMBRICKI LI: Yeah.
And also, earlier
in the talk, he
was talking about
when he was young.
He was doing magic.
And then he went into this
story about his mentor,
who is this giant
personality-- you
know, found the cure for polio,
did all these amazing things.
And when he showed the photo,
he was just like, you know,
this average Joe.
BRIAN ZAGHI: You're
expecting a giant.
ZAMBRICKI LI: You're
expecting someone.
He cured polio.
He did all these amazing things.
And then he's just-- you know.
And I think that's, like,
a big part of what it is.
It's like the biggest
minds or the people
that change the
world are not always
Andre the Giant or whatever.
It's just like--
AUSTIN BISNOW: It could be.
ZAMBRICKI LI: It could be, yeah.
But it's just Jonas Salk
from Queens or whatever.
So it's kind of
like the name came
from compressing the
entire Peter Tunney TED
Talk into two words.
LAURA MURPHY: Yeah.
Being five foot nothing, I
can relate to that mantra.
I like that a lot.
AUSTIN BISNOW: No,
you're a giant.
ZAMBRICKI LI: And
that's the thing.
You don't have to be
big to be a giant.
LAURA MURPHY: That's
very inspiring.
I do want to give you guys
a few more minutes here
because I was so
fascinated, one,
not only by the show last
night but just even talking
to you guys for a few minutes
about where you want to go.
I'd love to hear sort of,
after the end of the tour--
which I know ends
around Coachella,
giant headliner there--
what do you guys sort of see
as the future of the band?
Do you see yourselves taking on
another giant tour right away
or time in the studio?
AUSTIN BISNOW: Maybe we're going
to be software engineering.
I'm not sure.
LAURA MURPHY: Or
software engineering.
ZAMBRICKI LI: Yeah.
I mean, we've been
writing on this tour.
So we have one song
that we just started
playing kind of like every
night we played acoustic.
So probably, by the
end of the tour,
we'll have it worked
out enough to record it.
So we're going to
record a new song.
We're going to keep writing.
AUSTIN BISNOW: We have
more tours coming up, too.
ZAMBRICKI LI: We have
more tours coming up.
AUSTIN BISNOW: We might
go back to Europe.
LAURA MURPHY: Oh, nice.
ZAMBRICKI LI: You know, we
have this really cool community
of people that have been
kind of coming along with us.
And, you know, we want
to keep that going.
I think, like, fans are cool.
But community's better.
So, like, anything that
we can do to kind of keep
fostering that as we
keep working on music
and planning out everything,
that's what we're going for.
LAURA MURPHY: And that
Coachella concert--
I don't know, festival--
that you have coming up,
are you ready for that?
Do you think that's probably
one of the bigger shows
that you'll headline this year?
Or do you have plans beyond
that that we don't know about?
ZAMBRICKI LI: We're
doing Bottle Rock, which
is in Napa, which is also--
LAURA MURPHY: That's in Napa.
Is that after
Coachella this year?
ZAMBRICKI LI: Yeah.
It's after, yeah.
LAURA MURPHY: I think it is.
ZAMBRICKI LI: So, yes, we're
looking forward to that.
I mean, yeah, we're definitely
really excited about Coachella.
It's cool because
it's two weekends.
We play both Sundays.
So it's like it's a
whole little chapter.
So it's going to be really good.
LAURA MURPHY: Yeah.
Everyone in this
room knows about it,
but YouTube puts a lot into
broadcasting Coachella live.
AUSTIN BISNOW: Right, they
do the whole live thing.
LAURA MURPHY: Yeah.
We'll all have to
check it out and look
for when your set is
on those two weekends
so we can watch you
guys on YouTube Live.
AUSTIN BISNOW: I
know it's on Sunday.
ZAMBRICKI LI: Yeah,
it's on Sunday.
LAURA MURPHY: Oh, Sunday?
AUSTIN BISNOW: That's as
much as we know so far.
LAURA MURPHY: The first
or the second weekend?
ZAMBRICKI LI: Both
weekends, yeah.
They do a mirror.
It's the same exact
lineup both weekends.
LAURA MURPHY: OK, awesome.
Yeah, and they have
cameras on each stage.
Great.
Awesome.
BRIAN ZAGHI: Right on.
AUSTIN BISNOW: One thing we're
doing is, for every album
that is purchased at a
show, we plant a tree
through an organization
called One Tree Planted.
That's something we're
passionate about, too.
LAURA MURPHY: Do you
solicit funds for that?
I know you give your own funds.
But do you take donations?
ZAMBRICKI LI: We have
worked with matchers, yeah.
Like, some people have matched.
Like, we'll do a tour.
And then we'll get, like,
a partner for the tour
that will match
every one that we do.
AUSTIN BISNOW: And this
tour, it's GreenNotes.
And they're also doing
carbon offsets for the tour.
And we're doing bio-diesel
and, you know, no--
LAURA MURPHY: Zero emissions?
AUSTIN BISNOW: Yeah,
and no disposable
plastics that we have.
BRIAN ZAGHI: There's a cool
thing, the first I've seen it--
AUSTIN BISNOW: Oh, yeah.
BRIAN ZAGHI: We have
these VIP bracelets
because we have, like,
a VIP intimate session
before some of the shows.
And they actually
have these bracelets
that are made out of some
kind of biodegradable thing.
And they hold seeds in them.
So they're called
seed bracelets.
So when you're done, you
can plant these bracelets.
And, like, I don't
know what grows out
of them but some kind of flower.
Something grows.
LAURA MURPHY: Hmm,
what does grow?
ZAMBRICKI LI: Wait,
should we check
what grows before we give
them out to everybody?
BRIAN ZAGHI: No, I think
it's lavender, actually.
They said it was lavender.
AUSTIN BISNOW: They said
it was a sculpture of Zang.
Like, it's already sculpted.
BRIAN ZAGHI: A lavender bush.
LAURA MURPHY: Mr. Tango.
AUSTIN BISNOW: And
he's doing salsa.
It's just really cool.
LAURA MURPHY: Yeah,
that's very incredible.
Do you want to talk
about Mr. Tango at all?
It's kind of a phenomena.
ZAMBRICKI LI: You can't
talk about it because--
LAURA MURPHY: Oh, I mean,
it's not you, Zang, obviously.
ZAMBRICKI LI: He's only
Mr. Tango when he wears--
LAURA MURPHY: The fur coat?
ZAMBRICKI LI: No, he has
to be wearing the glasses.
AUSTIN BISNOW: You
spotted Mr. Tango.
LAURA MURPHY: Oh, do
you have to have--
AUSTIN BISNOW: I've
never met Mr. Tango.
LAURA MURPHY: I'm so
fascinated by these videos.
If you guys haven't
seen this, they
have a celebrity guest
called Mr. Tango.
And they follow him
like a paparazzi.
BRIAN ZAGHI: Yeah, exactly.
LAURA MURPHY: And your views
on those videos are incredible.
People love them so much.
And who is this sweet little old
lady in the compilation Tango
video?
BRIAN ZAGHI: That's
his grandmother.
ZAMBRICKI LI:
That's his grandma.
AUSTIN BISNOW: That's my
94-and-1/2-year-old grandma.
ZAMBRICKI LI: Yeah, she's 94.
We actually just went to
her home in Salt Lake City
and played some songs for her.
And, you know, she's 94.
And she's sharp as a tack.
And she's singing along.
It's beautiful.
LAURA MURPHY: I love her, yeah.
Actually, your
step-dad, I didn't
know that was your step-dad
playing football in your video.
ZAMBRICKI LI: He's
actually in our video
for "Window," as well.
He's like our Robert De Niro,
our internal Robert De Niro.
He just has this face where it's
just like, when he shows pain,
you really believe it.
Not everyone can do that.
You either have it or you don't.
LAURA MURPHY: But he wasn't
actually playing football
and tackling those guys, was he?
BRIAN ZAGHI: He was
playing football.
He was playing.
ZAMBRICKI LI: What do you mean?
Or was it a dream?
We don't know.
LAURA MURPHY: Or was it?
So whoever this Mr. Tango
is, how did that get started?
ZAMBRICKI LI: If you see
him, let us let us know.
LAURA MURPHY: I will.
BRIAN ZAGHI: We
also have a passion
for, like, just comedic skits
and video and things like that.
It's not just music.
We love other sort of
like art forms and things.
So we just try.
We imitate.
We have fun on our social media.
It's not just music, I think.
We love doing all sorts of--
AUSTIN BISNOW: Yeah, good
luck looking a Google Talk
with Mr. Tango because--
ZAMBRICKI LI: You can't get him.
AUSTIN BISNOW:
--he's hard to find.
ZAMBRICKI LI: He's
not available.
AUSTIN BISNOW: Yeah,
he's not available.
He's booked.
LAURA MURPHY: When
you guys hopefully
come through here again at
least in a couple of months,
our office is actually
moving to downtown Detroit.
So we'll have a
much bigger space.
We would love for
you to come back.
And maybe we can invite
Mr. Tango for a talk, too.
BRIAN ZAGHI: We'll
talk to his publicist.
LAURA MURPHY: Perfect.
Well, it's been an
absolute pleasure
having you guys here today.
Thank you so much.
Google, let's give them
a huge round of applause.
BRIAN ZAGHI: Thank you guys.
LAURA MURPHY: Magic Giant,
you saw them here first
unless you've seen them before.
But these guys are going
to be huge superstars.
So thank you so much.